obviously I have some takes where I mean
this is the show that airs tonight they
were talking about the person who the
trans prisoner she's getting a vagina a
free vagina or from the government
I think it was Milton Friedman who said
There are no free vaginas yeah and
everyone's all you know this outrage
free vagina our taxpayramony and I'm
like well it's an outrage that she's
even in prison because it was for a drug
offense so if you're gonna get mad about
wasting money then like why are we
locking up this person just because she
doesn't party the way the government
says is okay
so I do get a lot I'll get heat you know
from certainly people on the right but
there's people on the left they're like
she works at Fox News [__] her I want to
talk to her so it's like everybody hates
me